[Música]
bienvenidos a este programa especial la
serie de france 24
soy el mar y ángulo y en esta misión les
contaré cómo en medio de la emergencia
sanitaria global desatada por la
propagación del brote de koi 19 decenas
de campesinos policías guardias de
seguridad vendedores ambulantes y
domiciliarios estos trabajadores de los
cuales dependemos todos siguieron con
sus funciones sin importar el riesgo de
contagio en países como argentina
colombia el salvador ecuador e italia
iniciamos en argentina en la mayoría de
nuestras grandes ciudades la pandemia ha
cambiado el panorama de nuestros barrios
por varios meses las avenidas
permanecieron casi desiertas de no ser
por el aumento de los mensajeros como en
el resto de latinoamérica los
trabajadores de plataformas de
domicilios cobraron un papel crucial
son considerados esenciales tanto que el
gobierno argentino difundió el siguiente
aviso incentivando el uso del servicio
durante la cuarentena obligatoria se
puede pedir delivery si es más le
recomendamos hacerlo todas las veces que
puedas
esto pone a estos trabajadores que
realizan repartos a través de
aplicaciones en una situación compleja
tienen la ventaja de poder salir y
trabajar pero a la vez están más
expuestos al contagio la necesidad tiene
cara de paraguay se hace yo no trabajo
que me mantiene que me paga el alquiler
la asociación de personal de plataformas
el sindicato del sector emitió un
comunicado que dice trabajadores y
trabajadoras de plataformas digitales no
queremos ser héroes ni heroínas queremos
elementos de seguridad licencias y
compensación por cuarentena en principio
los repartidores con los que hablamos se
tuvieron que comprar sus propios
elementos de seguridad nos mandó un
mensaje cada 10-15 minutos media
distancia a un metro de distancia
consenso su protector normal de diarios
el barbijo guantes gel anti bacterial
algunas empresas de aplicaciones están
ofreciendo un incentivo en dinero de los
repartidores a los que ninguna considera
empleados propios hubo trabajadores de
plataforma que decidieron no salir y
priorizar el cuidado de su salud por
sobre sus ingresos como 'juan carlos
borges que vives con su familia en un
pequeño piso y prefirió recibirnos en la
entrada del edificio
mi decisión fue esa definitiva primero
tengo familia sí sí yo trabajo todo el
día creo que de repente por cualquier
medio me puedo contagiar y puedo llevar
el saco ese contagio a mi familia pero
él sabe que al ser cuentapropista como
todos los trabajadores de plataforma si
la cuarentena sigue extendiéndose
finalmente tendrá que salir
vamos a colombia porque en esta nación
fueron más de 250 mil guardias de
seguridad los que siguieron con sus
funciones sin importar el riesgo debido
a que fueron clasificados como parte de
las profesiones exentas por las normas
de confinamiento aureliano zamora fue
uno de ellos acompañamos a este
vigilante en una de sus jornadas
empieza otra jornada habitual para ahora
ya no zamora es vigilante y aunque todo
el mundo se quede en casa para evitar el
contagio del coronavirus o para nosotros
no no el cuarentena en colombia hay más
de 250.000 vigilantes y se encuentran
dentro de las profesiones exentas de las
reglas de confinamiento ahora él ya no
no ha faltado ningún día al trabajo
desde que la pandemia llegó a su país en
dos meses se jubilará y a los 62 años
sabe a qué riesgo se está exponiendo
para nosotros es política es un peligro
más si luego más duro o más de cuidado
que si llegara digamos un un ladrón a
hacernos daño ahí en el trabajo esto no
se sabe quién atrae
ese accidente es que un ladrón
físicamente uno ve al borrado y esto
pero de un virus de éstos no sabe quién
lo traiga entra al trabajo a las 5 45 de
la mañana pero por la escasez de
transporte público tiene que levantarse
más temprano para llegar a tiempo su uso
habitual fue cancelado
lo que ahora ya no se sube a otro aquí
es difícil respetar el distanciamiento
social y además es más caro y la gente
que normalmente trabajamos con un
salario mínimo a nosotros los patrones
nos van a incrementar nuestras porte
nosotros tenemos que sacar más plata a
nuestro bolsillo para poder llegar a los
los sitios de trabajo las calles están
desiertas pero alguien tiene que
garantizar la seguridad del edificio
aureliano y sus compañeros trabajan en
turnos de 12 horas y con la llegada del
cob y 19 las condiciones laborales
permanecen iguales
aunque en tiempo de pandemia tomaron
ciertos recaudos que la empresa nos dio
los tapabocas normalmente pues se tocó
hablar con ellos porque en el comienzo
que estaba un poquito como demorados
pero si demás pasan atrayeron tapabocas
nos trajeron este a este alcohol
antibacterial que se lo manejamos por
ejemplo en la recibida después para
desinfectar las manos el equipo de
comunicación todos y si bien aureliano
no estáis
como la mayoría de los colombianos
enfrenta al igual que todos la
incertidumbre ante el futuro
seguimos en el salvador allí fueron
decenas de trabajadores ambulantes los
que se vieron enfrentados al dilema de
arriesgarse para salir a vender sus
productos o aislarse y no poder
conseguir lo básico para comer y
sostener a sus familias conscientes del
peligro comerciantes como iliana ortiz
salieron a vender mascarillas en medio
de la emergencia aquí su historia
esta es la plaza libertad uno de los
puntos más emblemáticos y concurridos
del centro histórico de san salvador
donde a pesar de la cuarentena
domiciliaria obligatoria vendedoras
informales como iliana se arriesgan con
tal de conseguir algún dinero para
acomodar a mi lado la lana quería
guantes
aún no lo dejan vender porque no quieren
a nadie a nadie quieren en la calle no
quieren por por el miedo al temor al
virus entonces yo cuando me dicen que me
que no me quieren ver me tengo que ir
verdad antes de la emergencia nacional
iliana vendía verduras y sus ingresos
apenas cubrían el sustento diario ahora
la venta de mascarillas no alcanza ni
para eso que ahora con esto es muy
poquito lo que estoy vendiendo verdad
pero porque antes de invertir 150 diario
ahora invierto
10 dólares a ganar 5 dólares al día
gracias
el gobierno ha ofrecido 300 dólares por
familia para sortear la crisis
liliana prefiere no hacerse ilusiones
aunque es consciente que ese apoyo sería
de gran ayuda pues de momento sus pocas
ventas son el único ingreso de un hogar
de tres personas así que estamos con
este esperanzados a que el presidente no
nos dé este festivo para ya no venir a
vender verdad
la piel tostada y la garganta desgarrada
marcan el momento de volver a casa en su
hogar de apenas 4 metros cuadrados
la tristeza convive con la incertidumbre
de los días de encierro las pocas
monedas en el bolsillo le recuerdan que
debe mantenerse fuerte para combatir un
mal más agudo que el coronavirus la
pobreza
y del salvador vamos a ecuador porque
allí la labor de más de 57 mil policías
permitió que la seguridad reinara
durante el aislamiento obligatorio
decretado para intentar contener la
propagación del virus en este país
latinoamericano
el oficial wilson ayala fue uno de ellos
así fueron sus días en medio de la
emergencia
wilson se prepara para iniciar su
guardia a las seis de la mañana
enfrentar a un enemigo invisible es el
kobe 19 su vocación es más fuerte que la
duda en medio de una pandemia mundial él
vive en su comando mientras se supera la
pandemia para no arriesgar la salud de
su hijo al contagio quien sufre de una
deficiencia cardíaca me siento bien
haciendo lo que estoy haciendo y le
comentó una anécdota algo que me decía
mi hija recientemente me llamó por
teléfono me decía papi retírate ven a la
casa no puedo alguien tiene que hacer
este trabajo está consigna es clara y la
pretende cumplir vamos a patrullaje por
favor él se une los 57 mil policías del
ecuador
en medio de un toque de queda para
evitar contagios la medida rige a partir
de las 2 de la tarde hasta las 5 de la
mañana ingrese por favor ingrese las
sanciones por de larra van desde los 100
a los 400 dólares y hasta la cárcel de 1
a 3 años de sentencia
wilson reconoce que no escapa del temor
al contagio como funcionarios públicos
existe el temor la situación es que
nosotros como policías tenemos que
cumplir un deber
tenemos que cumplir un deber
constitucional que ellos intentan
surtirse de combustible durante el toque
de arriba lo más pronto posible 15
puntos de control establecidos en quito
donde sólo podrán transitar los
trabajadores de la medicina alimentos
bancos o sectores estratégicos avancemos
ustedes del hospital a base por favor al
hospital según la policía el índice
delictivo se redujo 10 por ciento nivel
nacional por el toque de queda no
obstante su oficial mayor dice que el
país no está listo para liberar presos
como lo exhortó la onu que tendría una
connotación distinta a un país que
europeo que tiene una estructura que se
llama fortalecida en ese ámbito de los
presos termina la jornada para wilson y
ninguna novedad mi mayor y mañana
enfrentar a una nueva misión terminamos
en italia donde a pesar del cierre y la
cuarentena por la pandemia el sector
agroalimentario nunca se detuvo gracias
al esfuerzo de operarios de centros de
distribución de alimentos los
supermercados de roma' permanecieron
abastecidos esta es la historia
desde la explosión de casos de
coronavirus en italia la actividad en
este lugar nunca ha cesado
estamos en una de las centrales de
distribución de alimentos más grandes de
la capital italiana
por aquí circulan más de 4000 toneladas
de productos alimentarios cada día
hacemos el pedido de los proveedores los
proveedores nos entregan los productos
aquí y nosotros recibimos el pedido y lo
inspeccionamos finalmente los
supermercados nos dan una lista de lo
que quieren recibir
unos 600 trabajadores reciben los
pedidos y preparan las entregas
su presencia es indispensable para que
los italianos puedan reabastecerse
durante la peor crisis que atraviesa
italia desde la posguerra
sabemos que el servicio que desempeñamos
aquí cada día no puede parar lo que es
realmente romper
y se rompería la cadena y esto
conllevaría problemas para la comunidad
grande
cada mañana a gregorio viene a trabajar
a pesar del riesgo de contagio que eso
supone
sabe que cada camión que sale de aquí
ayuda a los italianos a sobrellevar esta
difícil situación
tenemos miedo a contagiarnos estamos en
contacto con mucha gente como los
tenderos pero no podemos parar sino que
vamos a comer ha visto las filas en los
supermercados del mercado hay leche
aceite enlatados pero también comida
congelada y productos frescos en esta
cueva de alí babá se encuentran todo
tipo de productos agroalimentarios un
centenar de camiones hace de dos a tres
viajes al día para que los italianos
puedan comprar en supermercados con
estanterías llenas
y llegamos al final de esta serie sobre
las historias de esos empleados de los
cuales dependemos todos esos gracias a
quienes todas las actividades siguieron
funcionando a pesar del aislamiento
sigan con más esto es france24
[Música]